[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum Ryan I bit my tongue
like a week ago and it's making me talk
differently sometimes and sometimes on
certain vowels
and when I swallow it feels like I have
a sore throat but I don't
what the hell man I know you guys are
bored out of your mind not a way to
start the podcast but don't do that if
you have to talk for a living guys oh my
gosh I know man I have a a tendency to
just bite my tongue I should bite my
tongue more often you know what I mean
yeah
hey lady
uh hey this weekend I'm gonna be in
Pittsburgh
steel city con you gotta go it's gonna
be a riot I mean Chevy Chase is going to
be there Beverly D'Angelo uh you gotta
go I'm gonna be there with Kristen crook
it's gonna be fun you gotta go go on
Twitter go on Instagram get your tickets
we'll see you there
um
and we're doing a show stage it go to
stageit.com
s-t-a-g-e-i-t.com or you can go to
sunspin.com and get tickets to see our
show they're pretty much free but we're
doing a Christmas show on Sunday
December 18th 2 p.m 6 p.m uh we're gonna
play some music from the new album the
old album from left on Laurel maybe a
Christmas song or two we're gonna be
jolly we hope you join us for a
Christmas special uh December 18th also
go to sunspin.com right now you can get
this the new album out it's out now but
it's not streaming it so if you want to
Keepsake get a cool CD if you want it
signed we got shirts we got uh t-shirts
uh mugs calendars go to sunspin.com get
all that you can also book the band and
I'm on Cameo for the holidays that's it
for me
um we got a great guest today
uh make sure you follow us on our
socials Ryan at inside of you pod on
Twitter at inside a podcast on this
Grammy Facebook that's it yeah we got a
great guest today I mean Sam Yeager I
didn't know a lot about him and it's
amazing how much you learned I fell in
love with this guy he's amazing I mean
uh devil in Ohio
um the handmaid's tale he's done so much
been in a lot of movies you're going to
recognize when you see me but I know
that guy what a great story he has to
tell I know Ryan really enjoyed this
especially I text Sam I think after and
said Ryan really liked this it was good
uh yeah you don't always like stuff as
much as I do I like this one a lot you
did yeah so let's get inside of Sam
Yeager it's my point of view you're
listening to inside of you
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience right you're gonna be right
here with me
is it made does it make you
uncomfortable that Ryan's right there no
it's just lovely
he won't he won't bite it's varying
levels of comfort between guests please
don't please don't I have people call
him out I haven't been bitten since this
morning so if you do just bite me on my
right arm instead of my left my
six-year-old usually attacks that side
so who who has called you out Ryan on
the podcast who's like you know made you
part of the podcast it's generational I
will tell you is it really it's old
older the older guys Jason or Robert
Patrick Robert Patrick won't recognize
you no they know they take full notices
what's your name Anthony Michael Hall
Anthony Michael Hall Pete Holmes did
Peter yes yes but yeah but he's uh he's
also just large so I think it was just
within his wingspan yes did Apatow
really never know not really minding his
own yeah you're hoping he would have no
I didn't know he's a big fan but you
were hoping he would have you know kind
of called you he rejected my pilot he
did to tell them to help with that guy I
don't have a pilot he'll never work in
this town again bastard
um he's one of the nicest guys it's
always good and you know you like just
meeting you you're walking up the street
and I'm like you know you could have
parked in the driveway but I don't have
your number because your publicist of
course or your agent they didn't you
know yeah I should have said park in the
driveway but you know then you're
walking up you're kind of what kind of
cheap podcast is this not with that
sweet ride in the drive I was gonna I
wasn't going to be with that it's a new
truck man that is a new electric truck I
do love it I'm happy for you do you and
the world more people like you
obnoxiously large cars that don't
pollute I mean it doesn't pollute no
yeah it's all electric yeah it's
fantastic do you still like uh I mean
you're like in your 40s you're married
you have four kids yeah do you still
have certain things that you're like a
like a boy still like you like your like
things you're like you're oh yeah like
do you like any kind of toys or
memorabilia or because like if you look
around my house you obviously see that
so it's awesome you know I'm I'm the I'm
the bachelor yeah you know well I got
you know it's uh man that's a good
question I keep I keep I I keep trying
to make movies and when I start to make
movies I always end up buying an old car
and so I right now for this one indie
film that I'm kind of in the early
stages of I was like you know this this
character has a specific car he needs to
drive and so I went out and met this
hippie out in Altadena who was selling a
1965 of white Mustang that was so beat
up it's like you know he found it in you
know in Lompoc with like a paint can
stuck to the hood and right and I was
like well this is perfect for you know
but it stayed in my driveway for a very
long time so I'm a I'm a uh I guess uh
not a reluctant car collector but an
accidental car collector because that
will come and sit and and I did a
feature film my first 12 years ago where
uh take me home yeah the character gets
into a cab and talks the cabin into
driving her across the United States and
I was like well I'm just gonna buy a cab
so we bought a cab the crew and I like
the the week before we started shooting
actually we started shooting we didn't
even have the cabs and then we finally
got it and we drove it all the way
across the country it had 325 000 miles
on it for the film you actually drove
this cab the crew went across the
country with it with you yeah yeah six
uh six crew members and my wife and I
and uh yeah so after that experience I
had you know I just drove the taxi cab
around for a couple of years and and you
know you kept the taxes yeah it was my
main transport you know around town and
it had the writing on it and all that
stuff yeah in fact one time I went to a
meeting at Sony and I was driving around
the parking lot I was late this thing
and I'm driving around this woman stops
the car this is in this Sony you know
four-story parking lot and she goes I
roll down the window she goes can you
take me to my car
and I go of course uh well I'm I mean
I'm not a real cab driver I'm uh I'm
just going to she goes oh you're an
actor
in a taxi cab
okay well can you take me to my car
anyway and I said yeah sure happened you
did so I drove this woman around like
six floors she couldn't figure out where
her car was and I dropped her off and uh
you know and then was even later to the
the meeting but uh that's hilarious I
mean just to keep your taxi and driving
a taxi all around town yeah and how old
were you this was 12 years ago yeah yeah
I think I was did I have yeah I was I
was 30 something early I'll tell you it
is I I actually directed a little
independent raunchy comedy that you know
didn't cost a ton of money to make and I
wrote it directed starred in it just
like you yeah and when I read that you
did this and take me home and your wife
is in at Amber yeah I thought I gotta
ask him how I mean because this it was
the hardest thing I've ever done I don't
know how I survived everybody was
talking to me trying to talk me out of
it they're like you won't have enough
energy to move no you'll be so exhausted
you won't and there were a couple of
days where I thought I'm not I'm saying
this it sounds like I'm sure I thought I
was going to die yeah I thought I was
going to just collapse and they're going
to bring me to the hospital yeah there's
an enormous sense of Panic it's one
thing it's funny because a couple years
later I directed an episode of
Parenthood yeah and um in this one day
where we had a process trailer we were
shooting you know Interiors of a car
with this giant you know the car is on a
giant truck bed and you know at one
point we turned around and the the
energy of the car collapses you know the
the the truck uh
uh the electricity just goes out the car
shuts down we're mid U-turn and
everybody in the crew is flipping out oh
my gosh we I mean this is crazy we got
to move this stuff around and
everybody's in a panic and I thought
well this is this is new for me because
the cops are actually helping us they're
stopping traffic and instead of us
having to run from the cops which is
usually the scenario when you're in an
indie film you're like all right we're
gonna steal the scenario we're going to
steal this shot it's 11 o'clock at night
you guys look that way make sure there's
no cop cars you guys look that way make
sure there's no cop cars yeah so to be
in this set where I'm like oh no we're
legal here and we have people we have
Patrol officers protecting us from this
is like this is fine this is cake this
is that's funny you say that because I
remember I directed an episode of
Smallville and it was before I directed
a movie yeah and I was like oh my
goodness this is great this is easy but
little did I know it's easier because at
there's every depart is working with
they know what to do they know where to
be they know what to do and it makes
your life
tremendously easier just the fact that
there is a department yeah exactly and
you're not like wait who do we have food
for these people oh man yeah it was it
was I remember like day one filming our
movie called back in the day and we're
uh the first ad comes up to me and said
I go what's the problem they go uh the
crew and everybody has been standing in
line waiting for lunch to be ready for
like 15 minutes and it's not ready and I
was like it was like in the it's an
independent movie and I'm in Indiana and
so we had to talk to them and say hey
food has to be ready at exactly this
time there's no other and we just and
it's just like but when you're doing TV
the Parenthood you probably were like
this is a hell of a lot easier yeah no
problem yeah
was it
really difficult was it the hardest
thing you've ever done directing an
independent and being the star in it and
all that yeah yeah work wise other than
raising children that's far and away the
hardest but what about working with your
wife too was that did that put a kind of
a well she's a she was a great sport you
know like I mean I was uh you know we
were always every day was like a new
thing and uh I I I was
no actor should have put up with what I
put her through I mean it would be like
hey guys we gotta we are shooting this
scene in the forest because we had to
shift over because it was raining
somewhere else and so I was like hey we
got this scene where you're digging
through the mud trying to get your purse
that you chucked into the woods so we I
just I'm guessing there's poison ivy
here everybody get socks on and uh honey
you're just gonna have to just do it
we'll try and clear it out don't worry
about the lime and she got poison ivy so
bad that by the time we had driven out
to Utah we couldn't shoot half of her
face are you serious yeah because the
poison ivy had reached her face and so
we were like all right can't shoot
Amber's left side so uh and the whole
time she was just trying to navigate as
best and she was fine you guys didn't
fight you didn't Dicker no no I mean she
at one point she was just like hey I
just need to I need to I just need a
little space here just because I'm doing
the best I can but I'm I'm itching and
we need to go to urgent care to get
shots for my you know good Lord yeah but
but on the whole you know I had the
whole crew was like oh that was Far and
Away the best experience of my life you
know they look back on it as this
incredible trip across country our our
sound guy was uh this uh short uh
Spaniard who is that offensive Spaniard
I don't know okay good that's right uh I
don't know what else you would call that
person from Spain okay uh no no don't
ask me okay good well we'll stay inside
stay offensive
um but he was the only reason he took
the job was he had never seen our
country and so he had wanted to see the
United States and so you know traveling
with him he was just everybody was like
that was a marvelous experience and I
thought wow well I'm glad you guys
enjoyed it because I was just I hated it
that's the same thing the crew was like
this is the best experience the cast was
the best experience I've ever had uh you
know some of the crew got arrested for
you know drinking and getting up you
know and it was just it was like oh my
God the producer is great because they
kept me away from all the [ __ ] that was
going down I mean it was there was a lot
of [ __ ] going on and I mean people are F
and everybody yeah people people effing
people
um but you direct something like
Parenthood now you did you probably
acted like you know I I read something
like 100 episodes you acted in right
yeah something like that yeah and when
you're directing Craig T Nelson right
and these other actors was it
was a little bit since you're working
with them so much that you felt like oh
I had to prove myself because I felt
like that I had to show them that I know
what I'm doing you're in good hands
trust me did you feel like there was a
sort of yeah I think a little bit yeah
no
um uh you know and also I knew that some
of them wanted to direct and we're you
know looking down that so I think there
was there was a a light competition
maybe in were you the first that got to
direct I was the first and then Dax no
no Peter cross had directed the year
before us so and I think you know people
are worried once somebody one of the
actors directs and all of a sudden all
the other actors want to direct and it's
not really their passion but they were
like well that's an opportunity I should
take right and uh I had you know I if it
weren't for take me home I I wouldn't
have gotten the job you know but I had
proven that hey this guy can tell a
story and he's passionate about it so
um but yeah it was it was interesting it
was challenging and uh you know to add
to that um on the second day of shooting
um we were like hey uh somebody said hey
uh Ron Howard's showing up today and Ron
Howard had never he was an exec on the
show it was you know yeah derived from
his his movie and he had been on the on
the set yet and uh everybody was like oh
my gosh what's wrong I was coming around
you know like we set up this whole and
we had a big family scene with all the
actors in it and uh everybody I remember
somebody coming up to me and saying uh
well are you are you nervous and I said
well not I mean what's he gonna do
Rana like Ron Howard's we've been making
money for him for a couple of years he's
going to show up on set and be like
that's a bad choice no he's gonna be
like wow this is great I'm glad you guys
are I love this show and I'm I'm glad
you guys are carrying on and carry on so
and that's what he did yeah that's what
he did he was great he was great was he
like oh so you're the director here
you're in you're the actor yeah yeah
that's great what are you doing here did
he ask you what you're doing and like
well we had yeah we had a family scene
and it's you know it's a big messy
Family scene so I think it was fun for
him to see you know we shot that show so
fast it was three cameras and the
everybody was Mike and so everybody
could overlap and it has just that that
energy which is is fun to be a part of
inside of you is sponsored by better
help you know this holiday season do
something for a special person in your
life you
give yourself a gift to raise your
spirits and not just for the day look
the holiday can be a really tough time
for all of us between managing family
Dynamics racing from thing to thing
braving the cold and dark weather it's
it's normal to feel down having someone
to talk about how you're feeling and
what you can do about it is truly truly
a gift I've been doing therapy for years
it's important part of my life it has
become a part of my life it's become a
part of Ryan's life and I don't know
what I'd do without it and if you're
just getting started better help is the
perfect platform that's why they've been
a sponsor for a while because they
taught they see how we talk about mental
health and mental health affects
everybody including celebrities and
directors and it just it's it's
Universal it's it's a human thing and uh
we need people to talk to someone on the
outside that knows how to deal with
these things and helps us navigate
through life so I I strongly recommend
better help and so many people so many
patrons and listeners have emailed me
messaged me about how much better help
helps them
as the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched three million
people with professionally licensed and
vetted therapists 100 online plus it's
affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside inside of you
is brought to you by Shopify I don't
know what I would do without Shopify
Shopify is for everyone if you have a
small business big business you're
growing a business you want to sell
merch you want to sell anything Shopify
is the place I uh I started using
Shopify I told you the story but I had
like a t-shirt that's it to sell and now
I'm selling tons of stuff on both talk
Ville and inside of you podcast and
what's great is it's got the analytics
it tells you what with selling well
what's not selling well it's easy to to
navigate to use I recommend Shopify
highly Shopify makes it simple to sell
to anyone from anywhere whether your
thing is vintage tees or recipes for
ghee start selling with Shopify and join
the platform simplifying commas for
millions of your favorite businesses
worldwide with Shopify you'll create an
online store in your Vibe discover new
customers and grow the following that
keeps them coming back and thanks to 24
7 support and free libraries full of
educational content shopify's got you
every step of the way it's how every
minute new sellers around the world make
their first sale with Shopify and you
will too Shopify makes selling simple so
you can put yourself and your ideas out
there whether your thing is making
ebooks or earrings Shopify makes your
success possible running a successful
business means getting the insights you
need to grow wherever you are with
Shopify single dashboard you'll manage
orders shipping and payments from
anywhere when you're ready to launch
your thing into the spotlight do it with
Shopify the Commerce platform backing
millions of businesses down the street
and around the globe go on try Shopify
for free and start selling everywhere
sign up for a free trial at shopify.com
inside all lowercase go to shopify.com
inside to start selling online today
shopify.com
slash inside
was anyone difficult like you don't have
to say their name but was any of them
just it was like they were it was a
challenge to direct them they were like
they yes that sure was sure but you know
you it's it's it's more difficult
because I knew them so there were
certain times where people would try to
um get out of work or say hey can I I
don't know why I'm in this scene can I
just not be in the scene or you know and
you'd have to work around their
personalities that if if I worn a cast
member they would just be like well okay
I'll just show up and do my work but
right since they know me they were like
I don't know if I I don't really I don't
really I don't think I'm really needed
in this scene I was like yeah yeah it
was just you had to kind of suck it up
when you wanted to say dude just fine
this is your first time directing the
show just [ __ ] do you just do your
job yeah yeah oh and also it'd be like
you know you're just I'm gonna have you
done by 11AM
that's you know so if you can just give
me a morning you can have coffee come to
set and by the time you're done with
your coffee you get to go home so just
give me that was it I'm guessing it was
a male character it was not it wasn't no
it was so wrong I won't say anything
else no no I won't I won't put you on
the spot here but look you've like I I'm
already from just talking to you I could
see what like a nice guy you have this
easy going disposition you're you're
chill I could see why people want to
work with you I would see why you're
still married after all these years
you're just a calm sort of you can
listen and when you walked in here
before we started rolling you said I you
know I have ADD I have attention deficit
disorder yeah
and I was like well I have attention
deficit disorder there's no way you have
the tension deficit disorder we can't
all have it how is this possible what
what do you think of when you think like
you know when they say you have ADD
right okay Sam you have ADD
what makes that a reality to you what is
it that makes you have ADD uh well it's
you know it's funny I I'm I have a son
who was diagnosed with it and to look
back on how I kind of skated through
kind of accidentally or haphazardly
through high school and stuff with what
would have been a very tough time you
know it was still hard to focus in
school but I I was in cross country
because my brother ran cross country and
I think that you know running stabilizes
your brain in a way and I also you know
when I was 12 years old I went and saw a
Dead Poet Society and I came out of that
movie and I said to my best friend I was
like yeah that's what I want to do I
want to do that I want to act and I've
just pursued that ever since you know
for better or worse and uh and so that
was very clear you know if you know what
you want it's much easier to deal with
something like you know
distractions and and but uh but on like
I was explaining to my wife this summer
you know we we
um we remodeled our house recently and
we have uh a bunch of projects that I
was like okay I'll build the shelves
here don't worry about that and I'll be
build this and so but I'll be building a
desk or something and I will literally
have to tell myself as I'm cutting with
the jigsaw Sam you're cutting with a
jigsaw you are still cutting with a
jigsaw look at your hand look at your
other hand don't cut that hand continue
to cut and now you're done otherwise I'm
just going to be halfway through cutting
a board and be like oh well there they
go They're going there's my ring finger
isn't that bad it can be yeah well I
mean for example this morning
I was thinking my wife I turned uh I
wanted to make a little more coffee
because as you can tell you know
um you haven't even touched your coffee
I know but I have a summer start
drinking you made it for me and I think
there's a sip this where you don't even
have to take that off but I'm worried
that it's too hot because I don't want
to burn it off okay well thank you do
whatever you want I'm just coughing no
I'll find it I'll drink it like this but
this is a point being distracted this
morning I put the pot of uh under the
water filters in our kitchen I turned it
on and was talking to my wife and
halfway through it filling up because I
was making a pot of coffee she turned it
off and I and it was just like I don't
know if you want to call a
microaggression or whatever but I was
like what the why the hell she turn my
water off and then I flashed to all the
times that I had turned the water on and
left the room and then come back to a
flooded countertop you know like the the
water fills up on the cup and then it
fills spills out under you know like
probably we've only been in our home uh
not even a year and I've probably
flooded the counter about five or six
times really just turning the water on
and being like Oh I know what I gotta do
I gotta go write that email and you know
that's uh do you ever walk into a room
and go I forgot why I'm here every room
every room every room yeah and every
room I can't leave because I find myself
saying oh well I'm just gonna do this
now that I'm here all right yeah are
there other things have you ever dealt
with uh depression or anxiety or just
Aging for sure yeah you have that's my
bread and butter really oh yeah well
welcome to the club yeah Ryan's here too
oh man let's do it guys no this is the
place you know because were you were you
popular growing up
yeah I think so I mean I was I was uh
but I was a popular and an outsider I
think always because I didn't feel
um I didn't you know I loved growing up
in Perrysburg Ohio and I had I grew up
across the street from a baseball
diamond and I have a plenty of friends
but I just
um man I I think seventh grade eighth
grade where my son is now at his age I'm
just
that did me in you know just feeling
like I needed to belong somewhere and I
don't know where I belong uh it seems
felt like that in seventh eighth grade
you felt like you just didn't have a
yeah just like you didn't have a purpose
sort of or yeah it was just kind of
aimless and and and I think I just got
lonelier and lonelier because I didn't
like the way trying to be popular made
me feel so I didn't want to go down that
road and I I I found theater in high
school because I was it was one of those
things I was good at and girls
recognized me for doing uh adequately
enough and
um and I could just I could commit to
that I could go after school and build
sets and that that was a tangible thing
you know yeah and uh it was a safe place
but I I mean I felt I felt ugly I had
terrible acne and really yeah that's so
difficult oh that's really horrible you
had bad bad acne yeah painful yeah and
you know I think I spent a couple of
years feeling you know unlovable and uh
you know that's that I I think that I'm
grateful for it in many ways but it's
funny my wife is always like my with our
our middle son particularly she's he's
he's like a cherub he's like a living
cherub like with the the bow and arrow
and everything and um
and my wife will turn to me sometimes be
like
swear to God the woman that breaks his
heart the first girl that breaks his
heart in high school I am I mean that's
like I that's 10 years down the road
you're always you're already spiting
this poor girl like I want my kids to
have heartbreak because I think that
molds us in a way and it makes me it
certainly made me appreciative of of of
of where I am in life at all at any
given moment you know yeah it could
always be way worse because I remember
when it was you know and uh and I think
that's but I think I think depression is
something that you you deal with
um you know it's it's throughout life
through I mean it's something that you
just kind of Ebbs and flows it just sort
of all of a sudden you feel like God it
feels really sad I've done that where
you know I remember like it was like
probably a year and a half ago or
something I
my assistant Jessica at the time she was
downstairs and I walked in like good
morning how are you it's just good and I
go
I think I'm depressed um
and she looked at me she goes uh
okay
um should I call Dr kraussman I'm like
yeah yeah I think I should talk to
someone I just yeah they're just all of
a sudden you just feel this and you're
like what's why do I feel like this
there's no reason I just thought I had a
good time the other night and I thought
I and then all of a sudden nothing seems
kind of fun and you just get in a hole
and it's amazing how quickly it happens
two days ago you're I was euphoric and
then yesterday I was like oh Lord what
what is happening here for me I don't
know if did you grow up uh in the in the
church at all or no so I grew up going
to church every day I sang in the church
choir from like sixth grade Christ the
Lord has risen today every one of them I
knew them all and I could probably sing
them all verbatim but and and even the
the lesson like even like growing up in
the church you listen to like Amy Grant
and Michael W Smith like that's the
bread and butter and so a lot of a lot
of really painful soft pop music
so I mean and maybe that's part of the
depression I don't know maybe that's
knowing that I've got several Michael W
Smith songs in the back of my mind just
Loop what was his big hit
and a friend's a friend forever because
the Lord's a lord of them that was my my
oldest sister had that on a cassette
tape a loop and it would flip over and
it would play that song for 60 minutes
yeah but that might not even have been
his hit but it was that was what is
stuck in my brain I tend to play
sad songs all the time and I'll you know
and I told my therapist this and they go
okay I go you know that song
um
are you gonna stay with the one who
loves you oh yeah where are you going
back to the one you love and I just it's
like Glenn Frey old 80s Glenn Frey and I
go I just I feel like I play these songs
all the time like
she said well I don't want you playing
these songs all the time I don't want
you to play them on repeat it's okay if
you want to listen to the song but if
you're playing the song over and over
you're like living in this blooped sad
world that you want to live in you're
creating this world for yourself you've
got to get out of that yeah you've got
to stop yourself put on some happy music
or something a little bit different yeah
go outside it's almost like
sometime when we're feeling depressed we
just like embellish it or whatever I
don't know what the word is but we kind
of live in it like going look at me I
feel sad for myself right and that Loop
is so dangerous because one thing that a
diagnosis does is it feels like a life
sentence right like you said we'll we'll
have it forever but it doesn't mean
we'll have it every moment forever and
it also doesn't mean we you know there's
a possibility you know I there are
moments in my life where I'm much more
where depression is clings to me and
follows me and then there are moments
where I I think is it that I I was Diet
you know diagnosed with it and that just
lingers and so every default said
thought I have it goes back to well
that's because you're yeah you have
depression you have depression you're
depressed so you're allowed to feel this
so this is how you feel this is how you
should feel well yeah you know yeah yeah
and I and I I struggle with that quite a
bit you know what is what is depression
what is just a label I've had attached
to any sad feeling I have right but for
me the the the real depression going
back to the church I think derived from
this feeling of of their being an
afterlife and the comfort that that gave
as a kid and now that I don't believe
that there's necessarily a heaven
um that it it makes everything you know
there's that uh that underlies
everything for me and that's that's been
a hard pill to swallow it's been that's
that's my life's Pursuit is to try and I
do everything I can to try and get to
the other side of that and make peace
with there being a God or not being a
God and that's a
you know that's a daily struggle this is
kind of convoluted isn't it it is like
you want to believe we want to believe
that there's there's something else
there's a peace that there's I mean we
all want that and then a lot of people
are just like I I don't really believe
the atheists I mean I have a lot of
friends who call themselves atheists oh
you're not an atheist you believe in
nothing you have no faith in anything
and that's the point I I mean it's just
like have faith in something yeah and
then there are those people who just
have faith because I I must have faith
because otherwise I'll go to hell right
and it's like well that's not real Faith
yeah if you're just pretending to have
faith yeah so I try to really think that
hey there is something more this is just
one step along the way right whatever
that is whatever you think whatever you
think there's a heaven or they think
there's this other universe that you
kind of transcend into yeah spiritually
I think that you know for me anyway I
speak for myself but I think that
they're they're
I have these thoughts that there is
something else yeah that hey let's while
we're here you try to have memories
memories are all we have and you try to
be a good person you give to other
people yeah that's that to try to do the
right thing yeah and we don't always do
the right thing so don't be so hard on
yourself right and that's I beat myself
up constantly and that's that's tough do
you do you ever like have you with all
the work because we'll get into that I
mean you've done so much work and so
much good work yeah normally when people
say what have you done I name a couple
of things but then but you Parenthood
handmaid's tale why women kill traffic
Behind Enemy Lines Hearts War devil a
little high it's just like it goes on
I'm like looking at looking at the list
but had there has there ever been a
moment during all this where anxiety
sort of takes over or you kind of feel
like uh I don't have control of it I'm
too nervous I'm too or can you is acting
something that calms you is it something
that you it's you get away from that
it's sort of calm
the acting work is comforting but you
know you know as well as I do that that
is the reward you get for just years of
rejection and so you know I I have my
son my oldest son loves Legos and he I
was like hey there's this Lego
competition you know he's like Dad
um Lego has this
set building competition if we build a
new set we can win these bigger Lego
sets I was like wow that sounds pretty
cool you got a few days into it I said
well I'd be into he wanted to do it with
me and I said well yeah
let's build something cool and we got a
couple days in and he got really down on
it and he's because he had seen what
other people had built and he's like I
said what something's rubbing what's
going on here something's troubling you
he's like well I just don't know why we
should start because we're just gonna
lose
and I said I said buddy
um that's my job my job is loss all I do
is lose that's my career it's
hundreds of jobs that I imagine getting
I prepare to get and I don't get and
then the reward I get for accepting loss
over and over again is eventually I get
to do you know I get to act and and then
when that's done then I go back to
feeling like you know like I go back to
being a loser absolutely that's it yeah
and you know that you talk about anxiety
I mean two days ago I was like man I
gotta I gotta find I gotta carve out
more time in the week to to write and
work because I always feel like the lot
then the last job I had was the last job
you know that's it's tough too and
especially when you have a family to
take care of yeah and you're like I have
to now I'm giving you all the anxiety
now you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah you're preaching the choir I mean
are you someone are you pretty specific
in what you want to do are you open to
anything I mean I I
so last night I'm watching TV okay I'm
watching football Sunday it's football
well it's Tuesday now so two days ago I
was watching football because this air
is right right you know what I mean yeah
uh and I'm watching and I say oh an
all-new this show coming up followed by
this show followed by this show and this
show an all-new number one show of NBC
and I looked at my friend next to me and
I go
I never want to do any of those shows
ever ever No ever no and
you know but if you would have rewound
years before and I wasn't working and I
I had a family or whatever I'd be like
I'd love to be on any of those shows
yeah but thankfully you get you know
there's a time when you can you can
choose right but do you feel like you
can choose a lot more lately I mean
because doing Parenthood for years yeah
that probably helped you a lot you had a
little Nest Egg yes and this and that
and some things that give you a little
bit of a nesting then you do passion
projects like handmaid's tale which
you're probably not getting paid a ton
because it's HBO and you're just lucky
to be on that show you know they make
you feel like that like oh this is HBO
we're not going to pay it yeah you just
you're lucky you're on this show yeah
Hulu oh it's Hulu yeah handmaid's Tales
Hulu yeah yeah sorry it's one of those
but you know what I mean yeah but um I
don't know where I was going with this
but sort of like do you get to do you
are you choosy are your agents like what
about this what about that and you're
like why are you sending me this it's
not what I want to do are you able to do
I can do that a little more uh but you
know now the parameters are you know I I
was on the way out I was all it takes is
standing in customs for a couple hours
to for me to have a life crisis and you
know I emailed my team I was like hey
guys I can't work and I can't work in
Canada again uh not this year just
because I've been away from my family
for most of coven my wife is tackling
taking on three Maniacs at home and and
uh that's a lot it's a lot and I want to
be so if we can find a job that works in
town great even in the states great you
know and uh you know that said there's
very few jobs like that and and not for
nothing but you know I'm at a point
where I I'm never gonna I thought I was
gonna stop competing but it there's
there's always other actors you know
even in our our age it's never ending it
never ends and now it's because
television is where it's at I I compete
against bigger name film stars so
you know there's a there's a a a a kind
of a sweet spot where I'm reside where
people are like well we can't get this
guy but we can get this guy I've always
been that guy they can't get this guy so
let's give it to that guy or this guy
we're firing so let's hire this guy
totally which is you know which is fine
it's a great project you know sometimes
you luck out you're like oh man I'm glad
I did that totally it's funny I was
talking with uh Lizzy uh Elizabeth Moss
on on handmaid's tale and I said you
know what's funny is uh I uh I don't
know if you've had this experience but I
I there have been moments where I've
been only a few times have I been
offered a role but it was after they had
offered to someone else and I I lucked
into being you know I I was nosy and I
was like hey who who was the who was the
first guy offered and and um in one
instance it was Owen Wilson and the
other instance yeah yeah and the other
instance it was um Ewan McGregor I
thought well geez if I'm getting their
sloppy sucks I'm doing pretty good yeah
yeah I'd say so yeah and and Lizzy goes
oh yeah once
um uh there was a job that uh uh Kate
Winslet couldn't do and they offered me
and I was like sure I was like wow yeah
okay I guess I'm not to that level but
that's pretty sweet yeah Okay cool so
there's all these tiers of again yeah
you know we're you know it's tough
though because you're right they don't
but there's not a lot of I mean most
things shoot somewhere else because the
tax benefits right right so they shoot
now shooting Nashville North Carolina
and Louisiana and all these places that
you know it's just easier so but you're
still away from your family yeah and
it's tough yeah definitely tough
um
I mean that's got to be a big thing I
think that's why a lot of people
probably get divorced in this industry
oh yeah because they're away and then
they kind of or start things aren't
going well and they start talking to
some other guy on set right or the DP or
the yeah whatever yeah and things happen
so uh did that worry you at all when you
you know you I mean you met your wife
pretty young right how old were you uh
College we were College you've known
each other since College we were best
friends when we graduated college and
and joked about how easy and convenient
it would be for us to fall in love and
then about a year later we fell in love
it was pretty wild and then it's just it
was a nightmare for a couple years
trying to figure out what that meant and
uh and then we just you know we got
married we adult we had gotten all of
our best fights out of the way and uh
you know now there's just now now we
just they're expedited now it's just
like wait what the hell is your problem
okay this is my problem okay I need five
minutes okay I'm sorry okay who's gonna
take this no yelling yeah
you're kind of calm uh yeah and she
hates that she hates it yeah well and
also and also and also like I had
learned from my parents that you know I
had learned my dad kind of viewed the
world through rose-colored glasses and
my mom had a coping skill which was like
that's it I I don't want to talk about
it so when my wife you know wants to
deal with an issue she wants to deal
with it at that second and a lot of
times especially in my 20s when we were
in our having our best fights it was
like
uh I I would finally yell like I don't
know how I feel I have no idea how I
feel so I just need a minute you know
because I had never been bombarded with
trying to figure out how I felt I would
just feel something and you know smash
it down in the back of my brain and
never to have to deal with it so finally
you know I think one of the reasons we
we work so well together is we have
these different you know if we were both
raging that would be pretty bad and so a
lot of times somebody's got to be the
calm one someone's got to be the calm
one yeah and sometimes it's her you know
because I've had to I've had to up my
fight game you know I've had to be like
okay well just to get my point across I
have to raise my voice my friend just he
just got married I'm not going to
mention any names because you know
there's a anywho
um he said to me how's it going and he
looked at me goes I gotta tell you she's
really taught me how to fight ah how to
really fight and I go
[Music]
but you also want to have that moment
where you know that to her credit there
were you know big fights where I'd be
like I don't know how I feel I just need
a few minutes and my wife would go
fine and she would walk off and then she
would come to her senses and I'd come to
my senses it's you know there's there's
damage that can be done but there's also
a lot of repair and you have to you have
to focus on how how to repair after an
argument and and we do that really well
having a fight probably you know
if they're sort of intermittent if
they're sort of
they don't happen very often right it
could be good for a relationship to kind
of get it out you're like all right and
then it's like oh no hey this is great
if it's all the time it's just I've had
you know I've mostly I've had good
relationships for the most part where
it's not screaming at each other or yeah
you know I've had a relationship where
someone's just like I'm gonna leave I
don't wanna I don't want to talk about
this oh yeah oh man okay so now you're
like all right so you're you're immature
you don't want to have a conversation
about this that's right I don't like
your tone right now I'm Gonna Leave
This is my tone
until I talk yeah you know the thing I
love about having a partner that's like
wait you're dealing I I can see that
expression what's that about is there's
no there's no passive aggressivity we
don't have room for it it's literally
like she will pick up on every
expression even before I know how I feel
she'd be like what that's not okay
something something and I'll be like oh
Jesus Christ I thought oh I was kind of
just get in the car okay here's here's
the here's the problem this is you know
this is how I feel and then and then we
deal with it but yeah but there are
there are moments where you're you know
yeah you don't want to be in a situation
where you're just like she really taught
me how to fight yeah because yeah yeah
have you ever have you ever said oh [ __ ]
you oh sure you have [ __ ] off are you
kidding yes that's so healthy too
because yeah but you don't call each
other names no you don't say you [ __ ]
no no you know it's more like [ __ ] off
this is ridiculous what the [ __ ] are we
talking about that kind of thing exactly
I guess exactly I get you do you like
playing bad guys I'm just gonna go right
into it let's do it uh I do I do I
because you're really good because it's
not you yeah you know what I mean it's
like not I I look at you and when you
play a bad guy it's like you can really
turn it on
why women kill yeah
those are easy because I feel like I I
saw a Show recently where the the guy
was playing bad and it and it comes
across as a person playing back right
and so it's still the same work you know
you still have to find what makes this
person tick
um it's just what makes them tick is
usually narcissism you know like uh or a
a self-preservation and that's at the
heart of the the worst the worst people
on Earth yeah the the the people we
consider bad are usually just extremely
self-involved yes and that is true yeah
and so I think it's fun to kind of
explore explore that
um rather than jump into a
um you know kind of a judgment you know
again one of the things that my wife
does so beautifully is she doesn't judge
people the way I I did Growing Up well
that person's this way or that person's
this way right and so it's allowed me to
think more like my wife which is like
okay what makes this person tick so you
don't you're not judgy I am you are I am
but my wife is is not she's
far more forgiving you know to the point
where we'll be driving you know and and
you know somebody'll cut me off she'll
be like well you you know at least for
years she'd say well you know you never
know where they're going they could be
going to the hospital I'm like no Amber
all these people on the freeway cannot
all be going to the hospital nobody
there's not ten thousand baby deliveries
happening right now I could be pissed
about this one this guy's driving uh you
know a 2005 souped up Civic I'm guessing
he's not driving his pregnant wife to
the hospital he's just cutting me off
you know I have a friend Tom
Lally he's my best friend of all time
I've known him since I'm 12. grew up
together in Indiana
he's like that it drives me up a [ __ ]
wall you know same thing he'll be like
uh I'll be driving if that guy just
[ __ ] cut me off and he'll say
something like well maybe he's not
having a great day yeah
yeah oh shut up shut the hell shut up
I'm now I get to judge you for not
judging him yeah I remember I've gotten
in some fights with him I'm like why are
you going with him why are you always in
the middle when obviously clearly I'm
right why are you on my side you're
never on my side bro he's like man man
[ __ ] off that's it yeah that's well I
will say that I mean I guess I have that
tray where I I find you know I try to
understand all standpoints but my gut
read my knee-jerk reaction is usually
like what an [ __ ] oh yeah or I don't
like this person I'm a good judge of
character oh when I meet someone I'm
like I don't ever want to hang out with
them Ah that's interesting I don't I
know within minutes where I'm like I
know who this person is even though it's
judging yeah I just in my heart like the
way I feel yeah they're making me feel
maybe inadvertently I'm sure it is but I
just I I know like
that's I could tolerate this person but
I don't want there's some red flags life
yeah really quickly that's interesting
yeah I have I have terrible for uh
instincts on first meetings really
horrifically bad my my one of my closest
friends I met granted at 4 45 in the
morning handing out keys at the Reebok
Sports Club New York and and he was you
know and we shook hands and I was like
well this guy said you know I I walked
in of course the first day of work to be
like hey how are you I was like hey any
we didn't talk for five minutes by the
at the end of those five minutes I was
like well I don't want to work with this
loser ever again hopefully I don't get
another shift
obviously tired yeah yeah I'm like over
eager because I'm like hey how's it
going yeah I know it's 4 45 I guess I'm
ready to make sure I'm a great guy right
now let's talk no I don't want to you
have to understand that people don't
always they don't they're not on your
level that's right no you're right
that's true uh what would you say is the
Fate your favorite role that you've
played and all these things I've talked
about what is the one that you just
think I gotta say this one this is the
oh man because there's different
questions I want to know what's the most
challenging role you've played yeah
what's the the role that you really look
at and you're like I just love playing
this guy I wanna I wanted to continue
playing this guy oh
uh there's a man there's a lot you know
it's uh I love being on Parenthood I
loved I who that character was he's very
close to who I am so so you know I I
also
I like what I learned on certain shows I
guess I don't I guess I don't it's not
necessarily the character that I I'm
like oh man I'm gonna miss that
character
um because I they're still I feel like
they're still part of who I am and but
um but I I miss experiences you know I
miss and and
um handmaids is a great example of like
I I have this very particular role he's
kind of stoic and keeps to himself and
holds all his cards and uh there's a
lesson there you know for me which is
you know watching Lizzie moss do her
work there's a Stillness and a
specificity she has
that uh and still a tenacity you know
she's present but she's always she's
always aware of what the camera is doing
and how and her effect on it and I think
I can learn from that so I just try to I
just keep trying to learn you know
really so you learn from everything yeah
or else you know
what's the point you know I've seen I
remember seeing the actors I loved from
the 70s do projects that I was like I
don't know what I mean this is a
paycheck and uh that has to be done like
you said yet family care for and stuff
but I I I just wanna I wanna keep
learning and kind of tricking myself or
proving myself in a way that surprises
myself and others you know because I
because the second you're like well I
can I can do this you know that's pretty
boring work you know I almost didn't do
this uh show devil in Ohio that uh came
out on Netflix last month because
it was a contractor and a family man and
I and they were like hey they really
want you to audition for this and I said
well if they need to see what I'm liking
that there's 103 episodes of a show
called Parenthood and they can look at
that I've done that yeah and come on
this is easy yeah yeah but you know
again did they do that no they were like
well they they just like to see you uh
sometimes it's more about let's see if
we like this guy right if we want to
work with it right let's see what he
gives us let's see his interaction with
us he's gonna be easy he's gonna be one
of those pains in the asses that's
always calling us unchanged in the lines
and late to work yeah oh he's friendly
which I like Sam so that is it Jake or
Jaeger it's funny so this is funny I I
actually had this this conversation with
my team I read this book
um uh called predictably irrational and
it was all about how the Myriad of ways
we make decisions and how
um we think there's sound you know paths
but they're really arbitrary and silly
means by which we we make our the
decisions and I said so Guys these these
people want me to audition for a show I
don't know these people from Adam but I
read this book and one of the things
that they said is a good predictor of
whether you can you know whether people
feel invested in you is whether they
feel like a connection I have no
connection with these people so what I
need to do is if we can get the Creator
on the phone I can talk to her for 10
minutes and then we have a relationship
and that's what we did I met Darian we
talked on the phone and after 10 minutes
we hit it off she had just had a baby
boy I had three boys we could talk about
that and uh I grew up in Ohio so I could
talk at nauseum about growing up in Ohio
and how specific it is and um and so
when I auditioned I said okay now I'm
comfortable to put myself on tape for
this and work and so when we did the
audition it was just a work session
because she was already invested and so
at any given moment I'm always like okay
can we get the Creator on the phone
because that's gonna go get me so much
further than whatever audition we send
out into the ether because I know
there's they're saying 400
tape on this and we're all pretty much
the same right and I also think that
I've said this before but there's
something about when you get an offer
for something you're like okay they want
me I wonder what kind part of me they
want what is what is it they want yeah
and then you're just unsure
but if you audition and they like it and
they cast you you're like I know what
they want exactly I gave them what they
wanted yeah there's some comfort
actually in a weird way about
auditioning that I I don't like
auditioning I'm not I don't I just have
to put a lot of time into it it's a lot
of work it's a lot of like I have to put
to be my best I need a week yeah I can't
uh I've never even when I wasn't known
at all
when I wasn't on the Spectrum I I would
my well that sounds
we can feed into that one but my agents
would say you know that I go listen
I'm not I I can't do more than one
audition in a week maybe two if it's a
Monday and a Friday right but I just
can't I can't I can't multitask I can't
I have to stay in this character read
for it and then move on yeah that's just
something I just if I'm gonna be at my
best absolutely did you feel like that
totally yeah and there are things I put
on tape and I'm like uh yeah I mean it's
good enough but I don't you know have
you ever gotten a brawl when you were
kind of good enough no I don't think
they have to be great yeah you have to
do your best you have to walk away
saying I [ __ ] kill that that's when
you know you have a chance yeah
absolutely
there and there are you know people are
like what's the best acting you've ever
done not the best role and I said well
the best acting I ever did was I put
myself I wasn't at it wasn't called for
but I put myself on tape for uh the
Cohen's Macbeth and I was and that to me
is the best I've ever done really and
nobody will ever see it you know but I I
remember crushed it yeah yeah and I had
put in like you said a solid week of
just those lines aren't easy no no but
you know that's it reminds me of the
Wilco song the late great Johnny Ace no
is that is that the name of it but it's
about uh you know like the best life
never leaves your lungs and it's all
about these bands that you know that
never made it yeah you can't hear it on
the radio right and I think there's a
there's there's a Bittersweet quality to
that you know yeah yeah you're uh so
you're like you're 45 right have you had
an any major loss in your life that's
really affected you have you dealt with
that because for me I've had two real
major losses
um my grandmother
and my dog and those affected me like I
never thought they would affect me I I I
was just crippled by it yeah I had never
cried that hard I've never felt so much
so much emotion have you have you ever
had that
well I've lost grandparents I I don't
have uh I don't have any grandparents
left and they all died at pivotal ages
when I was 10. my my great or my
grandmother on my mom's side died uh I
guess seven or eight years ago and uh
and she was beloved
um but I feel like you know I feel like
I've
I real tragedy you know real
um
has has evaded me you know the the you
expect your your grand yeah
um you know and I I I know it's coming
that's what's yeah you just can't dwell
on it but you sometimes you get caught
up in thinking about things that haven't
happened yet oh yeah and you're like and
you can't you can't be thinking about
something that hasn't happened that's
anxiety right and we we do we're humans
we're like what am I gonna do when my
mother gets to be there who's going to
take care of what am I my dad dies how
do I take care of it I don't like all
these things could just make you go
crazy yeah and you just can't do that so
do you just not think of those things
yeah I mean I think I'm able to it's
hard I mean I I have a I battle with a
sense of hopelessness that I think due
to you know growing up in church and uh
but I but anxiety about other people's
deaths I I I think I worry more about
death as a whole for all of us than I do
about specific loss I know that my
parents will die and and man
I I am so grateful to have had them in
my life even up to this day that uh
it will always be hard the idea of
losing them but they uh
but I'm so lucky I'm so lucky to have
been born into the family I was born
into
um losing my children would be
unbearable unbearable and so
um but what can I do I mean I I can't
spend spend my days thinking about
panicking about that or else I'll just
keep them all inside the house no guys
you guys are standing with no ones leave
you guys are standing with the cats
here's here's uh you know here's the uh
kitty litter that you guys can use use
that keep them all trapped inside keep
them all trapped my brother
um my my brother's
um adopted a
my my niece has autism and and she will
have it for her entire life and she's
um you know she's
she can't speak or she communicates
through an iPad and um my brother is you
know told me once
uh you know we talked to a counselor
about this and getting ahead of
ourselves does us no good what are we
gonna do when when we're 80 how are we
going to take care of her and who's
going to take care of her and where does
this responsibility lie and
and uh doesn't do us any good no good
it'll just destroy us so all we can do
is react to the day and uh and try to
live this day out as fully as we can I
have this thing where I do now because
I'm just learning from in therapy where
it's like a
uh what is it called it's called pattern
interrupt pattern Interruption so when I
start thinking about like oh my God you
know my dog is four she could she's 12.
I only have her stop yeah stop and then
you breathe and you do this thing that I
do anyway it's just like it just stop
stop stop that thought stop because
you'll just spiral you'll continue to go
down these you know and I just in my
mind does go to Dark Places sure maybe
it's because I just watched Dahmer the
series Dawn I don't know what it is
that's a it's very ridiculous oh my God
it's tough
um
exactly what it is
um what's next for you I mean handmaid's
tale still going yeah right so that's
season three is coming up season season
five is it season five is on right now
season five I know there's five and
you've been on since season three I've
been on since that's what I meant Season
Two Season Two I don't know what I meant
yes uh yeah we're handmaids is still uh
still plugging away it's crazy it's a
show that you know does better you're at
you're uh after year which is rare you
know usually being on the you know
network shows you're like wow we were a
big hit in those first three episodes
and then we skated for five years and
nobody ever mentioned us and the fact
that handmaids is still
you know trying to you know provoke and
you know yeah and uh people love that
show they do they do do they come up to
you could get recognized for that I do
yeah I do what do you get recognized
with your handmaids you get recognized
for Parenthood obviously yeah people
come up to what else uh devil in Ohio no
yeah and where's that airing that's on
Netflix it just came out last month and
was the biggest show on Netflix and in
the world before all these hits I just
did I mean you're the guy to go to we
gotta you know we'll hire someone we'll
fire them we'll then bring Sam on and
the show will become a hit take that
Owen Wilson yeah Owen Wilson
that's fantastic so handmaid's tale
season five yeah and devil in Ohio just
aired yeah on Netflix you got it you
could see this guy anywhere you could
also watch Parenthood where is that air
on Hulu now or that's on peacock peacock
which you know that's another thing I
would say about
shows nowadays you'd think that there's
so many shows there's that they need us
that they need me
because before there's just like three
networks yeah and you know you're
fighting against every actor to get a
role totally but now there's 50 networks
and there's millions of shows that no
one will ever hear have you seen a
chipmunk yeah what chipmunk yeah it's on
the seashell yeah seashell yes
totally it's next to 2B I was on uh I
did two shows for CBS all access which
now is part of Paramount plus which is a
better name on the whole because you
know uh for a myriad of reasons but I
it's so funny because now people are
starting to watch those shows but when I
was on CBS all access it was like I felt
like it was acting into a vacuum it was
like it's on CBS all access what's that
yeah
it's all context too I mean it like you
mentioned handmaid's tale I I it's a you
know it's a as as established a hit as
it as it is
um I was talking to my neighbor Armando
and uh he goes so so what were you what
were you doing up in Canada it was oh
I'm uh it's uh the handmaid's tale
hummus
I go what it was the hummus no the
handmaid's tale everybody still has he
goes I I haven't heard of it what is it
well uh biggest shows ever it's uh it's
based on a book I mean there was a long
you know but you know I think that's
always healthy to be like oh right yeah
not everybody knows these things we
think are so important or just a a flick
uh just a flicker yeah you know it's
true so yeah when one person's like oh
my God that's my favorite show ever I
love him about the next person can be
like I have no clue who you are I don't
care totally yeah I just I'm watching
Brady Bunch repeats right now I don't
know who you are yeah
um
by the way quickly have you ever been
Starstruck and by who oh yeah one of the
first jobs I did back in the day I was
uh Behind Enemy Lines which was Owen
Wilson
um but my scenes were all with Gene
Hackman and you had all your scenes with
Gene Hackman yeah I mean I'm just he's
just barking orders to us but it's Gene
Hackman and you know every day I was
just like oh my gosh did you talk to him
yeah was he cool oh it's so cool so cool
he he also and I had heard rumors that
he was Gruff and cold and stuff but he
had warmed up to us we were a you know
group of you know young 20-something
soldiers or whatever and he was you know
kind of we were in this we spent a
couple days in green rooms you know
sitting with him and one of my favorite
one of my two I got two great Gene
Hackman stories do you want to hear sure
go ahead okay you can edit out whichever
um the the first one was I I met him you
know we were sitting in the room and
kind of he's warming up because he was
you know kind of in his work and a
little you know kind of standoffish at
first but it warmed up to us throughout
the day and at one point they needed
everybody in a shot except for Gene
Hackman and this actor Bumper Robinson
and me and everybody leaves and it's
Gene and the two of us and you can I
look over a bumper and I can tell he's
stewing because he's thinking what I'm
thinking we have this one moment to ask
Gene Hackman anything this is our golden
opportunity and I'm sitting there
thinking maybe I asked him maybe ask him
about the conversation the the symbolism
of the jacket and the conversation what
did that I really you know and Bumper
Robinson goes uh hey uh Mr Hagman um
uh what was that movie you were in about
um about Bonnie and Clyde
oh no
and Gene Hackman looks at him and he
goes
Bonnie and Clyde
and bumper goes oh that's right that's
right that's right gosh and I was like
I'm not asking my question now you've
ruined it bumper that was our one shot
man oh my God
what's that movie you're in though oh
man oh my God and then but it was
awesome to watch him talk about acting
and how he just had a very grounded not
precious Viewpoint of it which is which
is cool yeah that's awesome you know
it's funny as we speak he's doing a
signing that he never does he hasn't and
my friend called me and said hey I'm
kind of doing the signing with him was
there anything you want signed whoa so I
ordered a Hoosiers poster and a Superman
poster and sent it to him and he's
getting him signed for me dude that is
huge I mean from Indiana has to have
Alexa I mean you got it dude that is
huge right and I'm from Indiana yes come
on man this is so great gotta do it so
that's gonna be a new hopefully if he
gets it done hopefully you know they'll
have a shining in here I'll I'll take
some poster off but what's the other
Gene Hackman story oh the other one was
um
maybe I shouldn't be doing this one well
you don't have to no it's okay uh uh I'm
not cutting it so you you better know
okay well it's about okay so he's old
it's easier no but it's about another
actor so he was so to give a name I
won't I won't name the name but he but
somebody was we were sitting there he'd
warmed up throughout the day and
somebody said hey you worked with the
so-and-so right and he gave he goes ah
they're like oh it wasn't uh it wasn't a
good experience
in English hey this is a big Hollywood
movie star and he shined as Gene
Hackman's smile about you know this
person and we were like oh what was it
he goes well you know how far are we
from the trailers you know like what a
hundred a hundred feet this actor
chose to that they they they you know
they're like yeah that person's method
right and he's like I don't know what it
is but it's a waste of time you know
we'd be you know we were 100 feet from
the trailer and she'd you call to get
her horse you know
to the she she could drive her horse to
set a hundred feet and uh I remember one
time she she came up to me and she said
you know um Gene I got this scene and um
I'm coming down the hill on this horse
and I gotta I gotta you know my
character was uh you know abused at a
young age and uh you know that's what
made her such a so Gruff and you know so
cold and distant and uh and you know so
I I gotta you know that's all the things
and she proceeded to tell me about the
whole character history of about five
minutes she said so so what do you think
and I said
well hell if you can tell all that by
coming down this hill I'd really like to
see that
and I thought wow that's yeah that's
Gene oh my God that is just like yeah
just do the job just do the job and go
home
all right real quickly this is fast
rapid fire this is [ __ ] talking with Sam
Yeager [ __ ] talking with Sam Yeager top
tier patrons get to ask these questions
go to patreon.com inside of you I love
you guys you make the show happen here
we go these are quick rapid fire ready
little Lisa do you have any pet peeves
pet peeves pet peeves shoot oh man so
many
so many uh
uh pet peeves uh oh
no no no no I was going to say something
about this is the only a thing that an
actor uh knows but sometimes people come
to you and they're like I can't I just
can't figure out where I know you from
and if that's the case don't don't don't
ask until you know don't ask until you
know it's uncomfortable yeah somebody's
like I don't wanna it's your resume a
flight attendant did it on a flight and
she goes I'm just trying to figure out
what it is I know you from and I said
this is a this is a lose-lose scenario
for me because you're gonna sound like
it because I'm I'm either Parenthood I
know nope not that I'm gonna go through
everything you're gonna say no and then
I'm just gonna walk off feeling pretty
dejected and it's just I just Googled me
yeah just just do that how about that uh
Bob K how is it to work with how was it
to work with Craig T Nelson awesome
awesome
very very funny charismatic change the
change the shape of our show and and
some of the you know uh it's just a
fascinating guy yeah that's another guy
I got so many stories about oh my God I
love it's come such a long way but I
just love him dearly Karina and what's
the best lesson you learned in this
industry
hmm
uh
just come as yourself you know you try
and you spend so much time trying to be
something else trying to figure out what
they want but if you just figure out
what you want and who you are I mean
that's you know that's a lofty question
but no I think it's true I think it's
like I I at a young age I wanted to be
Gary Oldman I want to emulate Gary
Oldman I wanted to and then somebody's
like there's a Gary Oldman he's got that
yeah he's Gary Oldman yeah be yourself
totally totally they don't want another
whatever yeah and you're not going to be
another yeah right yeah and what's
refreshing is when you don't apologize
for it you say well this is who I am and
you know as you know it you come up with
like uh I have like trading cards of
coping you know that I flip through
every time I don't get a job and it's
like one of them says yeah well [ __ ] you
guys if that's your choice go to hell or
I flipped a card again and it's like oh
well it just wasn't meant to be and a
lot of times you know it's like the best
card to flip is like hey it's not me
it's not meant to be the next one will
godspeed and just kind of make peace
with it good attitude good attitude Ryan
99 more any fun stories to share from
Eli Stone and did you enjoy breaking
into song and dance I did enjoy breaking
into song and dance especially not
knowing that that was going to be
something we were going to do on that
show as much as we did uh man I loved I
loved that was another show I loved
working with you know Johnny Lee Miller
who's just a tenacious fantastic actor
Victor Garber Garber and uh man that I
think that was I I don't have any
specific stories but I just love doing
it you know uh it was my first series
regular role and you always remember
that awesome yeah dude this has been
awesome this has been great man yeah I
love you being so open and and just fun
and telling me about your life and how
it all works for you and how you know
it's uh I didn't know you I know
that we have mutual friends like Erica
Christensen and oh you know who's the
best it was right around the corner from
me does she yeah she lives like a block
over oh man if I didn't she's been on a
couple times has she yeah oh man she's
adorable
Dax was on on the show on the podcast
um
I'd love to get Craig T Nelson he
probably wouldn't do it he doesn't do a
lot of these does it he may be in Hawaii
is that where he lives I think so
sometimes do you see him or hear from
him ever every once in a while I'll
bring him up but yeah yeah just you'll
call him or you'll text him I'll call
him yeah and he'll answer yeah how you
doing sir I try to give him a call every
year he goes he has his uh uh a a you
know uh anniversary and so I call them
congratulations congratulations oh why
you graduated me I just was drinking
last week I [ __ ] it all up that's
right the stories he tells from those
Golden Era I mean unbelievable I'd love
to hear so many stories from Poltergeist
oh my God remember when he does this
thing in front of the front of his wife
he pushes out his studies before after
after before after he's so great after
the stomach he's great he's great uh
thanks for allowing me to be inside of
you today man this has been awesome I
feel like I met a new friend ah likewise
man the fact that you're wearing a Carpe
Diem shirt my wife my mother my mother
buys me stationery because again Dead
Poet Society was my favorite movie
growing up oh every every year I'll get
some piece of stationery or something
that has that song it's like oh that guy
gets me my grandmother comes to him when
is Anya's shirt
oh it's Carpe Diem what is that
Seize the Day what it's it's Latin it's
don't worry about it don't worry about
it what the hell is this all right
thanks man thanks for having me Michael
what a treat
thank you Sam for being so open and
sweet and kind and you're talented man
love to have you back sometime tell us
what you thought of Sam if you didn't
know him
um I hope you enjoyed this
um and listen to the intro for all the
stuff that's coming up in in our world
if so I don't have to repeat it and
thank you to my special patrons who make
the show possible they give back so much
I couldn't do the show without them uh
go to patreon.com inside of you join
today help the podcast out it's the
holidays and now you got a lot to think
about but we're trying to keep this
thing afloat I see you guys at cons I
love you thanks for the support I just
saw a bunch of my patrons and um
San Francisco cool and uh some of them
are going to Columbus I'll see Raj and a
bunch of people in Pittsburgh it's such
a joy to see people who listen to the
podcast this one in talkville support it
support me and uh
I'm lucky I'm very lucky I'll just say
that right now it's time for the top
tier
shout outs for patrons here we go Ryan
Nancy D Leah asks Sarah V little Lisa
you Kiko Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert P
Jason W Sophie M Kristen K Raj C Joshua
D Jennifer and Stacy El Jamal F Janelle
B Kimberly e Mike E held on Supremo 99
more San Diego M Chad
d w Liam P Janine R Maya P Maddie s
Belinda and Chris H David Sheila G Brad
d Ray H correct top of the T Tom and
Liliana a Talia M Betsy D Chad D thank
you
Dan and big Stevie W Angel M Rhiannon C
Cory K devnex and Michelle a Jeremy C
gavinator David C John B Brandy T
Camille asks Joey M Eugene and Leah
Nikki Nikki G Corey Patricia Heather L
Jake B Megan T Mel s hi bland splanch is
in the room you can hear jingling
Orlando see Carolina or Christine s
Sarah s Eric a Shane r m r Andrew M
zatuichi 77 Oracle Karina n Amanda R
Amanda s gen B Kevin e Stephanie K
lena82 Jarrell Billy s ADHD Rox Todd you
heard that Luna R uh again
I'm not gonna say it but that's it the
patrons rock you guys rock I hope you
stick around I hope you don't get bored
with us
and uh I I hope you can continue to
support the podcast and that's all I'll
say
that's it that's about all I could say
that's it yeah you biting your tongue
I'm biting my
uh Ryan thank you for always being here
thank you for having me here yeah it's a
treat
um so that's it from myself Michael
rosenberman the Hollywood Hills of
California I'm Ryan Tay is also wearing
its black hoodie day just uh if you're
listening oh apparently it's black
hoodie day that's black hoodie day Bland
it's just the kind of day it is oh my
dog's so cute I love her oh hey a little
wave to the camera
we love you thanks for listening and of
course as always Ryan give her a nice
pet hello look how cute that is Ryan
little Blanche always be good to
yourself always be good yourself right
always be good to yourself always be
good to yourself we love you we'll see
you next week spread the word
[Music]